Speaker 1: There was a completely bizarre
dystopian rally over the weekend in Illinois.
This was a rally in support, supposedly of
Illinois Republican Mary Miller. Now, Mary Miller
once praised Adolf Hitler. We'll get to that.
Donald Trump spoke at this rally. Donald Trump
was completely incoherent. He looked disoriented.
He struggled to speak even in repeating some of
the same lines we've become used to ad nauseum
from Trump. He was visibly struggling to deliver
them. So first, I'll give you a reminder. Mary
Miller. The rally was in support of Mary Miller.
Here is older footage of Mary Miller who said,
Hey, you know, Hitler was right about one thing.
Speaker 4: Each generation has the responsibility.
Speaker 2: To teach.
Speaker 4: The next generation.
Speaker 2: You know, if we.
Speaker 4: Win a few elections, we're still
going to be losing unless we win the hearts
of our children. That's it's.
Speaker 2: The battle. Hitler
was right on one thing.
Speaker 4: He said, whoever.
Speaker 2: Has the youth has the.
Speaker 4: Future.
Our children are being propagandized.
Speaker 1: Yeah. And, you know, if you want
to make the case that the youngest generation
is going to decide what the future looks like,
you can find people other than Hitler who
have made similar points. So choosing to
quote Hitler and say that this is this Hitler
knew this pretty wacky stuff. So this is who
Trump went to Illinois to support.
That's who he was there to support.
Maybe the most bizarre moment of Trump's
speech. Trump mimicking weightlifting during
the Anti-Transgender part of the rally. There's
always an anti-trans part of the rally now.
Speaker 2: Yeah.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
There you go. So that's Trump. Yeah. This
is now a regular part of every rally. Trump
saying teachers should not be allowed to teach
transgender. Very strange grammatical syntax.
Speaker 2: No teacher should ever be
allowed to teach transgender to our
children. What you you will.
Speaker 1: Never, ever teach
transgender to our children. You have to. I
don't know exactly what he means. Teachers
shouldn't be allowed to mention that trans
people exist. What does that even really mean?
But completely mush mouth and unable to deliver
these these diatribes. At a certain point,
Trump endorsed. This is so funny. Endorsed Mary
Miller. I don't know that I've ever heard a less
enthusiastic endorsement. He's sort of like,
Yeah, you know, vote for her, she'll be good.
Speaker 2: Go out and vote for Mary. You'll
never be disappointed with Mary. She doesn't
disappoint people and she loves you very much.
Speaker 1: Yeah, you can really tell Trump is
viscerally committed to supporting Mary Miller
there. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Go and go and vote for
her. And then Donald Trump is now claiming
that the January six Trump Riot Committee
is using doctored video, doctored video to
make their points. Now, I have to tell you,
if the argument you're relegated to is the
videos were doctored, the testimony was probably
pretty damn effective. Take a look at this.
Speaker 2: To this day, the leaders of the
Democrat Party have failed to forcefully condemn
the violence and threats and hold the perpetrators
accountable. There could be no greater
illustration of the two tiered system of justice.
We've never had anything like what's going on
right now that we have in our country. Then the
fact that at the very moment the radical Democrats
were staging a ridiculous fake trial over January
six, their party leaders are saying nothing about
the violent intimidation of the United States
Supreme Court. They refuse to talk about it. They
refuse to do anything. As you have seen, the vile
group of unhinged partizans and craven lunatics
on the UN Select Committee are pushing a fake and
fabricated narrative based on doctored video lies.
Speaker 1: And by the way, I hate to interrupt,
but just the total. So Trump is lying to the
crowd. There are the blacks for Trump. People
are up on the stage, strategically placed
behind Trump and the channel broadcasting
the speech. Right side broadcasting is offering
a free gold coin if you text Trump. It's I mean,
it's grift upon lie upon grift upon lie.
Speaker 2: The money that is totally uncontested
by cross examination. The lies are
unbelievable. It's a disgrace to our country.
A bunch of rhinos get up. They're going to make
their name big for a day. Everything they're
showing is ripped utterly out of context, such
as when Liz Cheney, a real loser, she is cut out.
Cut out the part of my quote in a speech that I
made a certain speech that said that their voices
should be heard peacefully and patriotically. She
left those words out. Would you say, that's nice.
She left them out. It's a sham. Think of that. She
left out the words peacefully and patriotically.
Why aren't they investigating massive election
fraud and irregularities instead of investigating?
Speaker 1: Because it doesn't exist.
Speaker 2: The people who want to get to the
bottom of a rigged and stolen election.
Speaker 1:
All right. So you get the point there.
And there seems to be a growing sensation
within Trumpland that the hearings were much
more effective than they imagined they would be.
And this is why they're now relegated to saying
the video is doctored. The video is doctored.
That's what it is. The new story from Trump
and it's not new, but Trump is now regularly
talking about it is Nancy Pelosi allowed the
riots to get out of control. Trump has said this
a few times before, but now he's really piling on.
Speaker 2: And why didn't Nancy Pelosi and
the mayor of Washington, D.C. accept my
offer on January 3rd, three days before
of 10,000 soldiers or National Guard or
more? To protect the Capitol. You know,
they are in charge of security.
Speaker 1: Now, that is untrue. This
has been repeated many times. It's not true. First
of all, there's no evidence Trump made any request
to deploy 10,000 National Guard troops before
the rally. TRUMP It's been claimed there's no
evidence of that whatsoever, number one. Secondly,
Nancy Pelosi is not in charge. The Capitol Police
are in charge. The Capitol Police are overseen by
the Capitol Police Board and committees from the
Senate and from the House. It is not Nancy
Pelosi that is in charge. So that's a lie.
Trump also taking the opportunity to
mention that you should sign up for his
platform. Truth, social.
Speaker 2: Truth.
Speaker 1: Central Yeah, and saying there's
no free speech anymore, but sign up for truth.
Speaker 2: We don't have free speech in
America. Yeah. Go out and sign up now
for truth. Social issues on truth. Social. Yeah.
Speaker 1: Doing good. Very muted response there.
Truth. Social will ban you if you post clips from
the January 6th committee hearings. So not exactly
the unfettered bastion of free speech
that Donald Trump claims it to be.
And then lastly, not very patriotic.
Trump saying America is no longer a great.
Speaker 2: Nation, is Illinois heroes poured
our incredible they just went out and they
poured their heart and soul to make America into
the greatest nation in the history of the world.
They worked to make America the greatest nation
in the history of the world. But. It is no longer
a great nation. It is a nation in decline.
Speaker 1: Wow. No longer a great nation.
And of course, I thought the Patriots always would
say America is always great. It's always the best.
I guess now maybe an asshole country might
be better, I guess because Joe Biden is
president. So everything going wrong? Trump
completely incoherent and supporting someone
with no enthusiasm whatsoever who once explained
that Hitler was right about one thing that is
the modern state of Trumpism, and the crowd just
eats it all up. He could tell them anything and
they would clap and they would cheer. We'll have
these clips on our Instagram. You can find them
at David Pakman show. We'll take a break. After
the break, we're going to hear from some Trump
supporters at the rally. And my recommendation
would be get the children out of the room.